so Fox News propaganda's Tucker Carlson
who has spent over a year minimizing the
January 6th Trump riots said yesterday
on his program that he can think of no
no more Brazen attack on our democracy
then when the Biden campaign asked
Twitter to take down nude pictures of
Hunter Biden which are against the law
in Most states and violated Twitter's
own policies on revenge porn
that's what Tucker Carlson is pointing
to as the most Brazen attack on our
democracy
you have to see this and then we'll
discuss it 20 election Twitter did this
with the help of the FBI committing
censorship on behalf of one candidate
while working to hurt the other
candidate now one uh sorry I'm sorry to
interrupt already
uh pay very close attention to the
language he uses and I'm going to back
it up just a few seconds because this is
critical to understanding the
propagandistic value of this E.I
committing censorship on behalf of one
candidate while working to hurt the
other candidate
it is hard to imagine a more Brazen
attack on our democracy than this huh
this is not how our system is supposed
to work in fact it's illegal
what Twitter did is a violation of the
First Amendment as well as of
established campaign Finance law they
never declared those contributions to
the Biden campaign that's a crime okay
I think there are five lies in there
it's only a 28 second clip of which we
listen to 26 seconds and I think there
are five lies in there think about the
number of things that he gets wrong and
then we'll talk about the absurdity
bigger picture of this there's I can
think of no more Brazen attack on our
democracy well I can think of one it's
January 6 which he minimized and of
course many other attempts by the Trump
Administration over the four years he
was president to suppress speech to
control the media kick out Jim Acosta
all these different things I can think
of many greater attacks on our democracy
than when the Biden campaign said to
Twitter Hey this is revenge porn these
are nude pictures of an individual who
did not release them please remove them
that's not really an attack on our
democracy number two he says it's
illegal it's not illegal there I mean at
this point it's been what 72 96 hours
since the Twitter files uh was released
and
um look at look at serious legal
commentaries I don't see anyone even
arguing that there was a crime here
number three this was a violation of the
First Amendment no uh we're talking
about a private company Twitter it's not
about the First Amendment the argument I
think Tucker and others are making is
that indirectly
because the government
told Twitter to remove the posts it is a
violation of the first amendment of
course it was the Biden campaign not the
government at the time so for about two
or even three different reasons and
layers it is not a violation of the
First Amendment then he says it violates
campaign Finance laws now I this one has
to be explained to be understood
his argument
I'm being as charitable as possible this
is the best possible argument that you
could make his argument is
removing the posts of Hunter Biden naked
was financially valuable to the Biden
campaign like a campaign contribution it
would be called an in-kind contribution
and so it was supposed to have been
reported but it wasn't now you have to
prove that in court it's very shaky and
I can't imagine you could prove in court
that arguing for the removal of revenge
porn by Twitter is a contribution of
value to a particular campaign
Hunter wasn't running for anything and
it was against Twitter's own policies
and a crime in just about every state
now let's take a zoom out a little bit
the problem isn't really Tucker Carlson
specifically is it and what I mean by
that is we have a system that allows on
the one hand Tucker Carlson to speak to
a large audience on a set that you know
it it looks like this is news when you
look at this it looks like a news show
say things that are completely baseless
and meritless and without evidence in in
many cases and then if it ever leads to
a lawsuit and it goes to court
Fox News lawyers show up and they say
this is entertainment this is not news
and
um what he uses Hyperbole and
exaggeration as a tool to do an
entertaining show and it should not be
taken literally as though he is
reporting facts oh okay because Fox News
is really going very much out of their
way to frame all of this as being actual
news as the word suggests that's really
the bigger problem here and this is not
me calling for censorship I'm not saying
Tucker should be off the air but the
problem is that having it both ways all
the time presenting as news and listen
I'll be honest
much of the problem is media literacy
the people who watch Fox not from a
media criticism standpoint the way we do
but the people who watch Hawks to learn
things and to get news
they don't realize that it's not news
they are the perfect marks for such a
deception and it's an endless Circle I
mean at this point how many times have
we talked about it the circle simply
continues and the latest now is this is
the greatest assault on our democracy
what about January 6th never mind dozens
of other things that happened under the
Trump Administration nope
it's when the Biden campaign said hey
this is illegal revenge porn and it
violates your own policies please remove
it whoa the biggest scan I'm trying to
is could this be potentially bigger than
Obama gate
which by the way I still don't know what
that is it seems those are really the
big scandals and Hillary's emails this
is the alternative world
alternative Universe better set in which
the modern right wing currently lives
good habits have to be sustainable in
order to become habits it has to be
something you'll actually do and when it
comes to nutrition some people have
hours to plan out every meal their exact
vitamin intake I'm not doing any of that
I don't have the time here's what's
sustainable for me I start my day with
just a single scoop of ag-1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below